president joe biden has tested positive
for covid19 uh he has reportedly
had very mild symptoms up until this
point in time
um is fully vaccinated has received two
covet booster shots and according to
karine jean-pierre the current press
secretary is experiencing very mild
symptoms
uh there is very little additional
information right now you now know
everything that i know it is not clear
whether there has been contact tracing
done or whether that's even relevant at
this point joe biden is around a lot of
different people
all the time you will remember that uh
failed former president donald trump
also experiencing covet 19 during his
presidency
with trump it was so serious that he
actually was advised
to get to walter reed medical center by
helicopter sooner than later for fear
that he may not be able to do so under
his own power if they waited and his
disease progressed uh donald trump had
trouble breathing and it was a serious
case of covid
um and joe biden is even older than
donald trump uh older than trump now and
older than trump was at the time that he
had covered so we wish him the best we
don't know of any reason at this point
that joe biden would be unable to
discharge his duty as president of the
united states turning over power to the
vice president kamal harris but we are
going to watch it that is the
information we have as of right now and
uh within within hours there indeed may
be more all right a bunch of you sent
this to me and i want to actually take
the time to go through it
there's a clip making the rounds on the
internet
called charlie kirk destroys crazy
eco-nut student that's the title of the
clip charlie kirk is
sort of like a ben shapiro type
character who goes to college campuses
and he debates
college students and he speaks very
confidently and people in the background
clap and it sort of comes off like
charlie kirk is
smart and
articulate and factual most importantly
it comes off like he's owning these
college kids with facts and logic
and he's not and that's why this format
that these right-wingers have developed
is so terrible so let's calmly go
through it this is about climate change
a student who is admittedly not well
prepared tries to confront charlie kirk
about um uh anthropogenic climate change
meaning human-caused climate change and
charlie kirk comes off like he's doing a
good job
but it's all bs okay so let's just let's
take it one claim at a time and tell me
if this is useful no question will be
here
what's the last question
sorry we got it sorry thank you uh yeah
first of all sorry for laughing when you
were talking about the environment uh
because it's just completely ridiculous
for you to suggest that
can you prove to me carbon dioxide is
the only reason why the atmosphere is
heating
okay
so already we have a problem
can you prove to me
that carbon dioxide is the only reason
why the atmosphere is heating so we can
now calmly think about that number one i
don't know anybody claiming that heating
is the only way we notice climate change
we're talking about erratic and extreme
weather more record highs more record
lows unseasonable weather extreme
weather events like storms sea level
rise uh et cetera okay so so
charlie kirk is asking for a defense to
a claim that's not even a good claim and
then number two
co2 is the cause of climate change i
mean we're really talking co2 is one of
the ways that we see the impact that
we're having but we're really talking
about activities generating electricity
by burning fossil fuels manufacturing
and industry emissions which release
numerous gases co2 being one
deforestation using transportation
producing food powering buildings they
all relate to emissions
and emissions include co2
but it's overly simplistic to say co2 is
the cause itself
well trees need co2 so we shouldn't be
worried about that that's the claim they
like to make
the point is everything is falling out
of balance and when he frames the
question in this simplistic way
prove
prove that carbon dioxide is the only
reason climate is warming we're not
talking only about carbon dioxide and
we're not talking only about warming
okay next they move on to sun spots the
only reason necessarily also not just
carbon dioxide because there's methane
and there's a lot of other gases
greenhouse gases are causing uh climate
change like this is a huge driver in
climate change and do you think sunspots
have any sort of contributing factor
not to a point where we can say that
that it's just not so why is it that
okay
sunspots charlie kirk says well maybe
sunspots are the reason for climate
change well climate scientists agree
that sunspots and even solar wind could
play a role in warming but warming is
only one aspect of climate change and
the role of sun spots has been studied
the vast majority of climate scientists
say the role of sunspots is
minimal absolutely minimal
and really the causes of of climate
change are industrial activity there are
thousands of peer-reviewed studies to
back that up now you can come in and say
well all of the science is just wrong
all of those scientists are wrong and
later in the segment charlie kirk does
basically say that but now you're
arguing that they're getting everything
wrong and could science get something
wrong of course but is it likely that at
this point they're getting everything
wrong on this issue no it's not
particularly likely so now let's
continue and now they they use it
charlie kirk uses another talking point
say that it's just so why is it that in
northern scotland back in the 1700s they
had a mediterranean climate what made
that change the climate fluctuates
naturally oh it does okay so
okay so this is another popular talking
point if industrialization is
responsible for climate change why was
it so much warmer in northern scotland
in the 1700s than it is today why this
has been widely studied and there's
actually four of these examples that are
often cited
northern scotland was mediterranean
there were vineyards in england england
in general was warmer and there were
vineyards during the medieval period
because it was so much warmer greenland
used to actually be green
newfoundland was full of grapes meaning
it also had a much milder climate
so it's been studied these this is not
new ground the idea with charlie kirk is
he says this stuff to people who have
never heard it before
some of these beliefs are based on tree
ring data tree ring data is not the most
accurate for evaluating temperature
since it can be affected by rainfall and
some other things but it's something and
it's quite possible that there were some
warmer moments before industrialization
that's not really a big deal
second it's not clear that in all of
these popular examples newfoundland
greenland etc it's not clear that
they're actually referring to the
specific places on earth that we think
they are because there have been changes
to the way we as humans refer to
different places so part of it is they
may be actually referring to slightly
different locations longitudinally and
latitudinally number three
no one's denying that there have been
periods
of warmer and colder climate over time
on earth the issue is that there has
been a consistency globally
to the warming over the last 100 years
and particularly the last 30 years than
at any time during the medieval period
so you could identify some microclimate
differences
uh you know microclimate being like san
francisco if you go just north or south
of san francisco it's like super hot a
lot of the year but in san francisco
it's cooler
you can identify microclimates whether
they're scotland or whatever it doesn't
disprove anything about the broader
climate change caused by
industrialization um okay let's let's
continue next they get to uh temperature
fluctuations yes yes this is outside of
human emissions no no no okay look
listen to me right now you're clapping
it shows ignorance right there because
yes there's natural fluctuations in
temperature however
humans are causing climate change we we
know this the evidence shows it and
you're being ignorant honestly okay so
what evidence are you talking about okay
so this is where they kind of love to
wrap you up or you go well it's only
huma human activity causing climate
change and then they get you to admit
well no there are some natural
fluctuations again you can't fall into
this stuff of course there are
fluctuations over time we've had ice
ages and then the ice ages end nobody's
denying that
what we know right now
is that much of the change that we're
seeing is not at all natural it's
happening much more rapidly than other
natural fluctuations have happened and
when you look at ice cores which let us
see conditions going back 800 000 years
when you look at pollen remains and
ocean sediment and glaciers and more you
know today that there is much more
methane in the atmosphere than at any
time in the last eight hundred thousand
years these are not little fluctuations
that go with ice age or whatever uh and
we can see over a longer period of time
now uh then they get into whose evidence
can you believe whose views can you
believe ipcc climate change report so 97
of scientists agree that one yes the
science of democracy
do we vote on do we vote on gravity
we reach consensus
the way the scientists are trying to
consensus
with a consensus on newton's second law
here's the problem i want to know yeah
there's consensus no it's 100 because
it's proof you can't prove it here's the
issue yeah yeah we don't you don't have
an up or down vote on things you're not
a scientist i want to know what the
three percent believe you know why
because usually the three percent
dissenting opinion against the majority
is the one that we should listen to the
most that's called the scientific method
so that's just wrong i mean it's uh
unless you have some particular reason
to believe that the three percent is
correct then the 97 percent is wrong
there's no particular reason that we
should listen more to the three percent
than the 97 percent and even that number
is wrong it's really more like 99.8 and
0.2 percent uh but
that's just that's just a
that's a meaningless claim listen to the
minority more why well i mean okay
listen to what they're saying but why
why do we give them more weight i'm
pro-science you're pro-mobocracy you're
pro-hysteria you're pro-panic
and by the way you're completely
ignoring the positive effects of a
changing climate for example the world
has never been greener did you know that
did you ever know that we have more
grassland and more farmland able to be
used for consumption ever before do you
know that okay so that's not really true
what that this talking point the earth
has never been greener
it's it's really only relative to like a
few decades ago and it is in a sense
true that over the last two decades
earth has increased its green leaf area
by a total of about five percent now one
of the major reasons for that is that
we're starting with a lower baseline the
deforestation of the 1970s
in particular
left us at a very low starting point and
over the last 20 years china and india
have done massive tree planting campaign
so they've sort of artificially bumped
up the amount of green leaf areas there
are questions about whether this
artificial greening
has the same carbon capture power that
one might imagine and the answer appears
to be no but this this is comparing to
the massive deforestation of the 70s and
80s let's get now to his claims about um
the safety of cold versus hot used for
consumption never before do you know
that less people live in extreme cold
than ever before and this whole climate
fluctuation okay
he i think he means fewer people but he
says less people live in extreme cold
than ever before they claim that this
like it's a good thing
heat kills way more people than cold
okay way more people on earth have the
ability to heat themselves when it's
cold than to cool themselves when it's
hot if you look at the availability of
fire
versus air conditioning heat related
deaths over time are estimated to be
more than five million people a year
uh because uh actually no five five
million is because of extreme heat or
cold
the majority of that is because of heat
and uh heat related deaths are are on
the rise whereas cold related deaths are
not in the united states it's also known
that heat kills more people than cold
and this is even accounting for you know
the this idea of the the homeless person
out in the cold in the winter
heat kills way more people so the idea
that it's good for humanity it doesn't
make any sense whatsoever let's listen
to the last bit nonsense we're only
dealing with a hundred year data set we
know that the world that the climate
naturally fluctuated okay so that's the
last thing i'll talk about the hundred
year data set
what they mean when they say that is
that modern historical weather and
temperature records only go back to
about the 1880s it's like 140 150 years
so it's true that modern weather data
only goes back that far when people
started measuring temperature more or
less the way we do now but as i
mentioned before we have 800 thousand
years of ice melt cycles we have glacier
data that's much older we have ocean
sedimentary data pollen layers and more
things so
the kid confronting charlie kirk is
unprepared no question whatsoever but
the arguments that charlie kirk makes
are all bad and in that format there's
no opportunity to really explore it but
when you break it down piece by piece
you see that that is exactly what it is
it's simply nonsense let me know if
these types of clips are useful i don't
want to spend a ton of time on this
because we're going to be covering it
live tonight but one of the things that
is expected to
be shown tonight at what is as of now
the last january 6th committee hearing
are videos of trump trying to record
that bizarre speech to the rioters right
after the january 6 riots and outtakes
will be published tonight during the
hearing which will show donald trump
struggling through his post riot speech
the report is that trump
was visibly struggling with what to say
not wanting to say certain things
clearly trying to
deliver a recorded video about the riots
that would not make trump look like he
was happy about the violence which it
sort of seems like he was but also would
not anger and isolate or alienate his
supporters and those are uh expected to
be
shown tonight here's a little bit of a
preview of that from last night on cnn
jeffrey uh the january 6 committee has
snippets of outtakes from trump's tape
message the day after the ride listen to
what this is what congressman adam
schiff told me about it tonight
there are people urging him to say
things to try to get the the
rioters the attackers to go home uh
there are things that uh they he can't
be prevailed upon to do and say not for
hours and hours
and and then ultimately when he does
give a statement still
things he wouldn't say and so
you'll have to wait until uh tomorrow
evening to see precisely what that is
we are going to be covering that live
tonight on youtube twitch and facebook i
hope that you will join me i don't have
more to say about it right now we'll let
those snippets speak for themselves
tonight find me on twitter at d pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
all right i want to show you another one
of these really dumb gas prices
conversations and i'm so sick of this
stuff and unfortunately sometimes the
left does it as well
former new orleans mayor mitch landrieu
is now a senior advisor and
infrastructure coordinator to the biden
administration he went on fox news
yesterday and was interviewed by fox
news host brett baer about gas prices
and they basically just got into
pointing the finger at each other about
the same game that both sides play with
gas prices and uh
bret bayer says to landrieu you're
giving joe biden credit for the gas
prices going down
but when they went up you said it was
vladimir putin and landrieu says to bret
bayer well you guys on fox news when the
gas prices went up you blame joe biden
and now that they go down you don't give
joe biden the credit and both are sort
of true and it's part of what makes this
all so very stupid things quickly one is
that you mentioned that the president
you're giving the president credit for
the gas prices going down but when they
went up it was vladimir putin and the
ukraine war well we could say it another
way when it went up you guys accused him
um for making it happen and when it went
down you forgot to give him credit for
it and so well he started going before
it started going up before the ukraine
war started
right it actually started going up
before biden was even president right i
mean that that's the funny thing about
it which is if you the the game that
bret bayer wants to play
is one that ignores that the gas prices
were actually going up under trump as
well and in fact i believe i have the
chart here which i can show you
um and if you take a look at this chart
let's look at the
yeah here it is so if you look at this
um in at the bottom for gas prices was
like late april of 2020. so gas prices
go up
in june and then they go up and up and
up and up and so the what happened was
that there was a demand collapse during
covid and then gas prices started going
up and then the ukraine russia war and
all these different things and every
country was affected by it so brett
bayer is playing the exact same game
here that they all play but that that
that is let me let me say this too the
other thing that's happening is when
when the price of barrel goes up the
price of gas goes up and when it goes
down it doesn't go down and the
president called that out and we need to
work on that too because it's the
american people that ought to benefit
okay yeah so you guys get the point i
mean i wish that they would just follow
my lead and say hey you know what brett
let's not play these games gas prices
are a global issue related to global
supply and only in a small way do
presidents make a difference on oil
price on gas prices and by the way in
the united states we have extremely
cheap gas compared to other countries in
the united states we don't accurately
price a gallon of gas to actually
reflect the true costs including the
environmental costs it's subsidized
the entire thing is a joke and you know
if it were me we should be moving to
electric vehicles but i know that that's
not exactly what they can say at every
opportunity but they're both
correctly
pointing to the fact that the other side
plays the exact same game abandon it do
what i've done since george w bush
gas prices up under bush doesn't really
have much to do with bush gas prices
down under bush doesn't really have much
to do with bush although he actually did
invade iraq which at least has
some connection to oil that is more than
what any other president could could
actually be um uh could be attributed to
other presidents with obama when the gas
prices were extraordinarily low i said
it's nice i guess for drivers but
it doesn't really have anything to do
with barack obama same thing under trump
and this is what you get nobody wins
from this conversation they each try to
make their political point they each try
to say the other side is playing a
political game and they're all it's all
true they're all doing it but we learn
absolutely nothing hey this was a very
strange moment yesterday uh joe biden
incorrectly said
that he has cancer and this was you know
hours before we learned that he has
covered but this was apparently just
sort of like uh he used the wrong word
and said had rather than have cancer but
this set off
a firestorm and frenzy of did did biden
just casually admit to having cancer my
mother drove us and rather than us be
able to walk
and guess what
the first frost you know what was
happening
you had to put on your windshield wipers
to get literally the oil slick off the
window
that's why i and so damn many other
people i grew up have cancer and why
can't for the longest time delaware had
the highest cancer rate in the nation so
he does say i and so many other people i
grew up with have cancer
he clearly means
had in his particular case
and immediately multiple reports coming
out saying what on earth is joe biden
talking about and the white house saying
it's a reference to when he had skin
cancer years ago
um mostly right-wing media outlets
initially jumping on it one of the first
reports was from the new york post which
is owned by news corporation joe biden
says he has cancer thanks to the oil
industry
but the white house points to skin
cancer years ago uh president biden said
wednesday he had cancer forcing the
white house press office to clarify he's
referring to skin cancer treatment he
had before taking office last year
it's unclear
what that
type of cancer specifically has to do
with oil but just sort of a confusing
hour or two the washington examiner also
white house denies biden has new cancer
diagnosis
um
the president uh the biden's latest
presidential bill of health notes that
prior to entering office he had a number
of cancerous lesions removed quote it's
well established biden spent a good deal
of time in the sun in his youth he's had
several localized non-melanoma skin
cancers removed
with moe's surgery before he started his
presidency there are no areas suspicious
for skin cancer uh at this time
and i guess quickly resolved but a few
moments there of serious confusion
um we've got the clip you can make of it
what you will on our instagram which you
can find at david pakman show after this
short break
i will be speaking to arthur brooks
arthur brooks was last on the show like
15 years ago when he was a professional
right winger he is in a much different
area of practice at this point i guess
we could say that's after the break
remember tuesday july 26th is our next
viewer town hall i hope you will join
everyone's welcome to call in and speak
to me it will be streaming live on the
pacman live youtube channel
youtube.compacmanlive
and um it'll be at 6 00 pm east
3 p.m west tuesday july 26th
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show today we're welcoming back arthur
brooks it's been uh it's been decades
since arthur has been on he's a harvard
professor phd social scientist
best-selling author writes at the
atlantic and the latest book is from
strength to strength finding success
happiness and deep purpose in the second
half of life which you'll at some point
in the next decade you will enter i
guess
well yeah if i'm not it's like enough of
life nowadays i'm going to be living at
least 116 years and that i don't know i
got the data seems unlikely
well you know aspirationally in the
jewish faith we say 120. you know so so
60 yeah yeah i mean you live to 120. and
by the the title of the book by the way
is michael
but from the 84th psalm may you go from
strength to strength that's where the
title of the book comes from that's uh
well there's some there's really
something for everyone i mean let's zoom
out a little bit
the the mindfulness space
the happiness hacking space you know
it's become so riddled with
newsletters
self-help books hacks the top three the
best ten you know all these sort of
different things and i get that they're
all kind of pointing to what it seems to
me is that a lot of people are
experiencing some kind of fundamental
absence of something
and
there's different ways that we can deal
with that either by sort of workshopping
and hacking for some it's finding
religion or higher purpose or faith or
whatever the case may be what's your
overall assessment of how this space has
become so huge in the last 10 years
well to begin with it's the reason that
we haven't mastered it i mean look we
all want to be happy and we're not so
obviously there's something wrong here
and part of the reason is because mother
nature is just lying to us all all the
time
the biggest mistake that we all make is
thinking that if we actually get what we
want we'll be happy that's completely
incorrect and it's based on the false
assumption that mother nature cares if
you're happy see mother nature is
is encouraging you to accumulate money
and power and pleasure and fame and
therefore and since you want to be happy
and you want those things you make the
connection of thinking if i get those
things i'm going to be happy well that's
mother nature's joke
she basically wants you to pass on your
jeans dave and she wants you to have 75
children by getting as rich and famous
as possible she does not care she
doesn't care at all whether you're happy
and that's the big mistake that we make
the truth is that being happy requires
that we do things that are contrary to
our basic nature a lot and most people
don't know how to do that most people
don't want to do that and that's the
reason that we still haven't mastered
this art
does this uh relate in some way to the
concept of the hedonic treadmill where
you identify what you think is sort of
like an end point at which you will
achieve some level of happiness or
satisfaction then you get there and it
turns out uh it doesn't really look the
same now that i'm here and you kind of
move goal posts is that related to the
same desire that that maybe is
not not what we think it is
very much so happiness basically comes
from three things there's sort of three
macronutrients in happiness kind of like
food is protein carbohydrates and fat
happiness is enjoyment meaning and
satisfaction those are the three parts
of happiness you have to have all three
and all three are hard all three
actually require work and they require
habits not hacks they require that you
take these things seriously they require
knowledge and and and and so the last of
those satisfaction is the one that
you're talking about satisfaction is the
joy that you got from a job well done or
getting a reward that you really wanted
mother nature tells you that if you get
that thing that the the joy that you get
is gonna last forever so mick jagger
sings i can't get no satisfaction but i
try and i try and i try now
the truth is that you can get
satisfaction the problem is that you
can't keep satisfaction that's what you
call the hedonic treadmill the science
behind that is a thing called
homeostasis that's where the brain
always goes back to its baseline so if
you in in your body just too by the way
if your pulse goes up after being on the
treadmill and then after you get off it
goes back down to your pulse your
regular pulse rate that's so you don't
die that's homeostasis but emotionally
or homeostasis means we can't stay out
of our groove by being happier than
normal because we won't be ready for the
next set of circumstances and the
pleistocene we'd be somebody's lunch
fast if we weren't ready to react
emotionally to the next set of
circumstances that's homeostasis but we
don't know it because mother nature is
lying to us and saying that new car
smells going to last forever that the
sunshine in california is going to make
you happy forever that that new romance
is going to give you a thrill forever
that my students at the harvard business
school when they get that great job it's
going to be awesome forever because they
got all this money no you'll like it
when you hear about the raise but you
won't even care about it when it hurts
you hits your check because of the
helonic treadmill so you need to hack
that you need new habits to get beyond
that and that's what i write about my in
the work that i do look that
self-improvement space is
not very scientific if you really want
to be happier you got to do habits you
got to do the work and you have to share
it with other people you need to become
a real student of this stuff and then
you truly can be happier you mentioned
there's so many of these different
instances that can be kind of delved
into more and researched more one about
the idea of if i move to a place with
better weather uh i'll just i'll i'll be
happier year round because when i'm
there for a little bit it seems so great
um there's a bunch of interesting work
on that and one study i read says that
it is true for like a couple years and
then it just kind of becomes the status
quo and then it almost starts to become
interesting to think about places that
have seasons that have winter and all of
a sudden that kind of becomes more
appealing there's also the counter
factual of of the in terms of
self-reported happiness
places with pretty crummy weather and
cold temperatures are regularly at the
top of self-reported happiness as well
which should make us it should make us
say what i guess
yeah i mean nobody says i want to move
to denmark for the weather right but
denmark comes out on top of these
happiness scales and comparisons of
people in different countries now those
actual comparisons are nonsense because
you can't really compare people in
different countries who have different
cultures but you can compare people
within regions and indeed you find that
in a lot of places like the upper
midwest people actually are they tend to
be just as happy or happier than people
in california and the main reason is
because weather isn't what brings you
happiness what brings you happiness is
your faith or life philosophy your
transcendent self sense of what what the
what the world is all about whether it's
religious or not your family life your
friendships and work that serves other
people in other words it's all about
love and in a lot of places in the upper
midwest they have better communities and
healthier families than they have in
places in southern california the key
thing to keep in mind is your brain says
to get that
unless you have a seasonal affective
disorder or something i'm talking about
people who don't and it's only about
seven or eight percent of people have
that but if you don't have that your
brain's saying you'll be happier in the
sunshine and you will enjoy it of course
i mean i've lived in southern california
periodically throughout my life
but the real happiness bump that comes
from happiness will wear off in six
months and the taxes are forever so
choose wisely
well so that that's where your uh former
professional conservative uh uh career
com comes out for sure uh which by the
way i wanna i wanna link back to all of
all of this in a bit so what are you
talked about there there are things that
you can do to kind of hack these
tendencies for lack of a better term so
what are they
well so the key thing is it's again it's
not hacks it's habits that's an
important thing to keep in mind because
everybody wants a shortcut and the world
is all about hacks you know i'm gonna
i'm gonna hack into somebody's system
i'm gonna hack my metabolism i'm gonna
you know i'm gonna hack my sleep and all
that and almost anybody who's promising
you hacks is selling you a bill of goods
anything that's really going to do good
for you requires that you change your
life you're going to change your you
change the way that you live you know
you can't hack your weight because what
you're going to do is quickly lose
weight on some weird diet and gain all
the weight back and then some if you
really want to be healthy anyway you
know all that people kind of know about
that so that's the key thing to keep in
mind the four happiness habits as i
mentioned before are faith
family friendship and work that serves
other people and so those are the things
really to be spending time on now to be
sure people have different metabolisms
you know i talked about the the the
three macronutrients but there's also
metabolism so david you and i you might
just be a naturally happier person than
me because 50 of your baseline happiness
is genetic you know i don't want it to
be true but that's very important
information because that's why your
habits are that much more important to
sort of epigenetically help you to
express greater happiness not
withstanding your genes a quarter of
your happiness is circumstantial but
because of homeostasis and the hedonic
treadmill the circumstances don't last
good and bad you know even if bad things
happen to you almost always that will
wear away pretty quickly and the good
things will too the quarter that really
matters is the four habits so the first
one is the faith thing and again that
your results may vary you've got to
figure out what that means to you if
you're not a traditionally religious
person then what we're talking about is
a transcendent view of life everybody
needs to understand their values and
live according to them people need a
contemplative practice people need to um
to
to surround themselves with literature
that's that's wise for example so i
recommend that people read i don't care
the stoic philosophers or the holy books
or or just something smart 15 minutes a
day that they engage in a practice of of
nature or prayer or meditation and that
they actually think very clearly about
their values so they can get that first
pillar that faith pillar in order right
family life is unbelievably important i
mean
i'm sure you join me in regretting the
fact that one in six americans is not
talking to a family member today because
of politics which is just
it's just like stepping over 100 bills
to get to nickels man right it is
insanity to do that i mean i know aunt
marge is the pain because she at
thanksgiving she can't stop talking
about trump but but man if you call aunt
marge at 2am with a crisis she's picking
up the phone and all your buddies on on
you know whatever the democracy
underground they're like who are you
that's important that we keep that in
mind and then when we when we talk about
uh about friendships
i mean people can't see us right now but
i'm wearing a t-shirt that says real
friends beat deal friends
and you know for the strivers out there
the super drivers it's all deal no real
we got to get that in order and finally
your work i mean we all work and most
americans like their jobs well enough
the key thing to loving your job and
having it bring joy to you is not i mean
it's got to pay well enough obviously
you got to pay your rent but it's all
about earning your success and serving
other people and you know that's where
really comes in and so it's love of the
divine whatever that means to you love
your family love your friends and loving
others through your work love love love
and more love you know if people didn't
know your your back story
i think the way you talk about these
issues
people would be surprised that you were
sort of like professional right winger
for a while running the american
enterprise institute and you know people
check out our conversation 15 years ago
or however however long ago it was they
might be surprised to hear you talk this
way is that
wrong or do you find that what you're
doing now
does appeal more to people on the
political left than the right
it appeals to everybody because
everybody wants to be happy you know i
have a completely non-partisan audience
i mean i write for the atlantic and you
know my personal i mean look everybody's
got their political views and one of the
biggest problems that we have for
happiness is america in america is we
we're too i identified our identities
are too political i mean david you and i
have you know 95 in common and the five
percent that's not is a bunch of
political views that would be relatively
trivialized if you were pulling me out
of a burning car absolutely you know
it's super important that we not get too
hung up on these types of things and
furthermore that we can love and respect
each other
not despite our political differences
but because of our political differences
as far as i'm concerned the most
interesting people are the ones who
disagree with me not the ones who agree
with me on every matter i mean none of
my kids vote like me
i don't care i mean it's like
all three of my kids voted for trump you
know and so it's is that true oh yeah
it's not my thing but it's it's it's you
know let's bring it on give me your
reasons you know i want to hear it is
the whole thing
more is the bottom line i think that
makes sense to a lot of people i think
where it becomes more difficult is when
the differences are
directly hostile to who we feel we are
right so differences between me and a
white nationalist for example
okay i mean it started we start to get i
think into that maybe it's less common
fortunately but those differences are
harder to overcome
they're harder to overcome but we're
having a tendency today because we're
being manipulated by people who are
making a big buck on our hatred
and us thinking that the differences of
ideology are actually in differences of
the of existence
and that's a big problem that we have
you know somebody who disagrees with the
way that i live my life is not denying
my right to exist those are two very
different things and the problem is we
become
too disengaged from our common story and
two i think involved in our differing
identities identities are like i'm this
and you're not so you're not in my in
group you're in my out group and you
know you and i as i said before have a
90-something percent overlapping common
story that is the basis of our
brotherhood sure i mean you and i are
just i mean it's super important that we
see each other as as you know with the
equal dignity radically and then if you
disagree with me really strongly about
something that's not my denying your
right to exist and and yet a lot of
scholars a lot of politicians
are trying to effectively a lot of let
me put not to find a point on it a lot
of people my age a lot of baby boomers
are trying to conscript a lot of child
soldiers into their culture war
by convincing a lot of young people to
be really hateful and afraid
of people who say one particular thing
or who have particular moral views as if
they wanted you dead which isn't true on
the right or the left yeah i i generally
tend to agree with that i think that
where we get into a riskier space is
when we minimize that there's lots of
people out there who maybe they don't
want to deny your right to exist like
maybe they're not talking about killing
those with whom they disagree but they
want to deny them basic rights and then
there's a question as to where do you
draw the line as to when are these just
casual differences which we can easily
overcome
yeah no for sure and you know if
somebody wants to deny your basic rights
and you can see that on both sides
constantly when i saw our our senator
elizabeth warren talking about crisis
pregnancy centers last week saying we
need to shut them all down you know and
you could take that and say oh therefore
under the circumstance there's nothing
for us to talk about we need to break
away as a nation there's no way that we
can live together or we could say you
know
people say these things they talk in
this particular way elizabeth warren
actually is a good senator who wants to
represent me she does a lot of things
that are right and not taking the most
radical thing that somebody says and
interpreting it in the most radical way
possible we got to be more charitable to
each other as the bottom line i think
that is a hard for me to disagree with
that's for sure uh we've been speaking
with arthur brooks his latest book is
from strength to strength finding
success happiness and deep purpose in
the second half of life arthur great
speaking to you again i really
appreciate it
you too neighbor um you know we're both
massachusetts natives although i know
our audience is far and wide you're
you're reaching even outside american
borders these days aren't you these days
yes uh and there are many people in
scotland resisting it i will tell you
we're not no i'm kidding yeah we are we
are and mostly us uh i'm sorry uh
english-speaking countries but big in
germany i will tell you
that's great to hear i'm glad to hear it
congratulations on your success you
deserve it
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
so i don't know how many of you saw or
remember the recent film with leonardo
dicaprio don't look up there's this
incredible scene where they bring on one
of the scientists who
um has discovered that there's this uh
comet or meteor i don't remember heading
towards earth and they say this is
happening it's going to kill all of us
and the news
reporters who are
uh oh man i don't remember the actors
tyler perry and oh man i forgot now in
any case we're going to look at it they
say you know we want things to be
positive here like okay yeah right but
we're all going to die if we don't do
anything and they go no but we we like
positive news here and
yesterday on gb news in response to the
insane historic heat wave that is
plaguing much of the united states and
europe there was almost the exact same
sort of discussion no we warm is nice we
like warm no
people will die no but it's it's so nice
when it's warm out we're going to look
here first ben phillips put this
together this is really good first it's
going to be the segment from the
satirical film don't look up
and then it'll be yesterday's segment
from gb news
and they're basically the same thing
are we not being clear
we're trying to tell you that the entire
planet is about to be destroyed
okay okay well it's um you know there's
something we do around here you know we
just keep the bad news light oh you see
john you're outside enjoying the
sunshine it's not too hot what is it
no it's it's absolutely lovely it's
about 20 degrees out here it's perfect
but um on a serious note folks um by
early next week
you can scrap 20 degrees it could well
be 40 degrees i think
there will be hundreds if not thousands
of excess deaths early next week
like that's bad news you don't want that
in front of me are frightening
so we all like nice weather but this
will not be nice weather this will be
potentially lethal weather for a couple
of days it'll be brief
but it'll be brutal
so you know we can
oh yeah so this is so john i want us to
be happy about the weather and
everything i don't know whether
something's happened to meteorologists
to make you all a little bit fatalistic
yes it's called reality
harbingers of doom because all of the
broadcasts particularly on on the bbc
every time i've turned on anyone's
talking about the weather they're saying
that there's going to be
tons of fatalities but yeah i don't know
whenever i look at more reputable news
outlets than ours they're acting like
this heat wave is a bad thing can't we
just be happy about the warmth we always
had hot weather
john i mean wasn't the 76 the summer of
76 that was as hot as this wasn't it
no
and you know we are seeing more and more
records more and more frequently and
more and more severely uh so yeah some
people always hop back to the summer of
76 which was a freak event 40 odd years
ago 40 years ago
but heat waves are becoming more extreme
this is yet another one which is coming
down the tracks towards us and you know
i don't think we should yeah so anyway
gb news is a right-wing channel backed
by discovery now discovery i mean
discovery's done really good stuff on
science and climate and so on um but
they are one of the backers as well as
some non-uk financiers for gb news
and i mean it's it's the same thing as
the scene from don't look up isn't this
nice it's sort of like the right wing
thing of listen trees like to breathe
carbon dioxide so isn't more carbon
dioxide a good thing and it has become
you know when when don't look up first
came out
it was a
it was like an extreme version
of this barrier head in the sand sort of
trumpism a parody of trumpism
now
the scene we just saw from the real news
is as or more crazy
than what we saw
in the film don't look up it's truly
bizarre stuff and uh reality mirroring
fiction at this point in a really
horrifying and scary way well last week
it was lindsey graham who was told you
are going to have to respond to the
subpoena and testify in the georgia
probe of uh the election fraud attempt
by donald trump in 2020. and now donald
trump's former lawyer rudy giuliani has
been told the exact same thing the
associated press is now reporting
giuliani ordered to testify in georgia
2020 election probe this is not the news
that rudy giuliani wanted now a few
important things to mention here first
and foremost as a reminder this is the
probe in georgia there is a grand jury
this is separate from the january 6
committee
they are looking into
trump and associates attempt
to take george's electoral votes from
joe biden even though joe biden won this
includes trump calling and saying i need
11 000 votes give me a break it includes
lindsey graham calling and saying well
can't we look into what could be done
now as of right now the last we heard
lindsey graham and rudy giuliani
received subpoenas but they are not
targets they are considered witnesses
the way rudy operates
he could make himself a target by
showing up and unknowingly implicating
himself and others that wouldn't come as
a huge shock but at least for now
lindsey graham's attempt to get out of
testifying has been shut down by a judge
and rudy's as well the ap says a judge
in new york has ordered rudy giuliani to
appear next month before a special grand
jury in atlanta investigating whether
former president trump and others
illegally tried to interfere in the 2020
election in georgia new york supreme
court justice thomas farber issued an
order directing giuliani to appear
before the special grand jury august 9th
and any other dates ordered by the court
giuliani's lawyer did not immediately
return a call
fulton county district attorney fannie
willis began her investigation early
last year
earlier this month she filed petitions
to compel seven trump associates
including giuliani and lindsey graham to
testify because they don't live in
georgia she used a process that involves
getting a judge in a state where they
live to order them to appear now here's
an interesting detail giuliani had been
summoned to appear in court in new york
on july 13 to present any reason why a
subpoena should not be issued for him to
testify in atlanta but he failed to show
up for that hearing
in a court filing wednesday willis
informed the judge over seeing the grand
jury giuliani had been served with the
final order instructing him to appear
it's possible giuliani could file a
motion with the court in atlanta to try
to avoid testifying
others have already filed challenges to
try to get out of that this is actually
the second time
that the same manhattan judge ordered
rudy giuliani to testify in the georgia
grand jury he was given a date
previously to appear and he didn't go
and now he's being told again to go on
august 9th so
if you said to me david you've got to
bet sir no odds just straight up
do you bet that graham and giuliani
testify or do you bet that they don't
i don't know which bet i take right now
it feels very 50 50. if you or me
if you or i
were refusing to testify
refusing to appear before a grand jury
after being subpoenaed especially when a
judge writes you've got to be there
um
we'd be in a jail cell awaiting trial on
contempt charges i presume but here
we're talking about lindsey graham
here we're talking about rudy giuliani
and uh
what's going to happen i really don't
know the relationship between this
investigation and the january 6
committee
it involves a lot of the same people but
these are two separate investigations
and i continue to believe
that if there will be charges levied
against donald trump they will come out
of the georgia probe not out of the
january 6 committee but i would love it
for charges to come out of all of them
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here's a caller who says if trump thinks
that by running for president again
he'll avoid getting indicted
he is wrong this is the opinion of the
caller
trump is talking about
running for president to avoid being
indicted
and there's no
that's not going to work
merrick garland is not going to stop any
indictments or investigations
just because he
declares that he's running for president
his only option is to move to another
country that does not
extradite extradite
and he'd have to stay there for the rest
of his life yeah i mean listen i
generally agree
that trump running for president is not
going to prevent an indictment however
it is completely plausible that if
there's an indictment forthcoming
against donald trump and donald trump is
again the sitting president it's after
january of 2025 trump won in november 24
is sworn in in 25
and then the indictment comes forward i
do believe that donald trump will at
least have a reasonable attempt to make
to say no no no i'm the president i
can't be dealing with this right now he
used it while president the first time
around to avoid having to testify and
respond to requests from uh various
women who had filed lawsuits against
donald trump so he will absolutely do
that but to the extent that trump wants
to from what we're told
get out of uh legal trouble in terms of
indictments by announcing his candidacy
i agree that that's not going to do
anything that's not going to work now
whether there's actually any um
charges forthcoming remains to be seen
we have a fantastic bonus show today
first of all
democrats forced every republican in the
house to take a stance on marriage
equality
and i know that it's july of 2022
but there are many
many
many house republicans who voted against
marriage equality secondly
joe biden has announced some incremental
climate initiatives we're going to talk
about what they are and we're going to
talk about whether they are more
substance or whether they are more
fluff this includes promoting offshore
wind
uh and some other things so we will talk
about that and also the the meaning and
discussion around declaring a climate
emergency and thirdly
there's a bipartisan senate group that
has reached a deal to reform the
electoral count act this is something
we've been looking at for a while and
this relates to the circumstances that
presented themselves after the 2020
election the mike pence etc craziness
there seems to be some progress among
this senate group we'll tell you what is
contained there and whether it might
actually more seriously prevent what
could have happened in 2020 from even
having a shot at happening in the future
get access to the bonus show by signing
up at joinpackman.com
you can use the coupon code obama
to get a roughly 60 discount off of the
cost of membership and lastly remember
i want you
to show up to my viewer town hall on
tuesday july 26th this will be 6 p.m
eastern 3 p.m pacific it'll be if you
want to watch it'll be streaming live on
the pacman live youtube channel
youtube.compacmanlive you can just watch
you don't have to participate if you'd
like to chat with me during the town
hall we will be live at 6 pm eastern 3
p.m pacific and taking questions via
discord and of course our website
members at joinpakman.com
will get priority access with a separate
member waiting room in order to talk to
me so all great things and remember
tonight 7 p.m eastern i will be
streaming what is at least as of now
believed to be the final committee
hearing for the january 6th committee
expecting excerpts of donald trump
struggling to report his go record his
go home speech after the trump riots uh
trump's former lawyer pasipoloni
expected to testify huge tonight we'll
be live on youtube twitch and facebook
and i hope to see you then i really do
you